a politically wounded joe biden is
turning to the squad for help the
president's disapproval keeps rising
with his popularity underwater by double
digits in 33 states
biden is facing a tsunami of bad news on
all fronts a former clinton pollster
summing things up this way
biden is getting hit by the four biggest
political crises of the past american
century
all at once quote
it combines the nuclear anxieties of the
1950s and 60s with the inflation threat
of the 70s the crime wave of the 80s and
90s and the tensions over illegal
immigration
in the 2000s and beyond
now you would think joe would try a
reset and tack to the middle maybe focus
on the problems americans actually care
about
but instead he's running full speed into
the open arms of the squad
and their far left agenda biden
reportedly looking at canceling student
debt as a way to bribe voters to the
ballot boxes this year and of course the
squad cheering on the move
our president has taken an oath to
represent all of us
and to care for the well-being of all of
us and what we are asking and demanding
today is for him to follow through with
the promise of canceling student debt if
we could bail out um
banks
that
destroyed the economy because of their
illegal activity
if we can give mr bezos 10 billion
dollars you know what we can do we can
cancel all student debt in
and the white house actually thinks
they're fighting inflation by freezing
student loan debt payments listen
the president's plan uh to address
inflation or address causes or costs as
they've gone up for the american people
has
many different components how the
american people experience inflation is
costs as you noted whether it's at the
grocery store other costs on their
pocketbook and the president has taken a
number of steps to address costs even
extending the pause on student loans
which is something he did just a few
weeks ago
trump's line of attack on joe biden
geraldo during the campaign he's a
puppet of the far left and now you see
the squad out there
bull horning and hair waving all over
the place and it looks like he's being
pushed over by the far left was donald
trump right about that i
don't think that that image has any
credibility i think when you see aoc and
you know oppressor the others out there
making these grandiose statements it's
not coming out of biden's mouth i'm not
a conservative
i play with conservatives on tv
but i'm telling you it's not about the
squad it's about russia threatening
nuclear war for the first time since the
cuban missile crisis i'm really worried
about the existential uh you know
phenomenon of an erratic dictator
rattling a nuclear saber i mean this is
nuts i'm scared to death about it but
that's not the issue of the topic we're
talking about him getting pushed over by
the squad are you going to change your
tune in a week or two when biden says
forgive the loan the squad can't even
get in the white house they it is they
are so irrelevant they're just an easy
target the fact of the matter is i think
mark penn was right the pollster that
you quoted at the top of the show
biden's problem is the confluence of all
of these issues at the same time
inflation and the economy that's a huge
hunk right there crime immigration
and then you have this uh this uh wild
card this uh crazy putin who's losing
the war in ukraine who could do anything
that was a smart assessment by former
clinton pollster it was mark penn about
these four crises he's facing you know
what it is it is a perfect storm
and now the american people understand
that what they voted for all 80 million
of them uh is not what they ultimately
got they got a guy who was incompetent
who is uh genetic uh cognitively uh you
know very simple
and you know only 19 of them want him to
run again and less than half want her to
run again so you've got a country of
people who are rising up who are angry
who everything is affecting them whether
it's immigration and crime and food and
and worried about russia and nuclear war
you know they were always like with
trump oh we're gonna have nuclear war
everybody in california it's gonna be a
nuclear war baloney there was no problem
then now there's a real problem and i
think that the the biggest thing of all
of this is that people need to
understand that they run and they say
things but in the end you have to look
at their history he's a man who's been
wrong on on on foreign policy his whole
life he's a he's a man who virtually did
nothing in the senate except become a
millionaire and pay off hunter's bills
but we're not going there but we might
later in the show
but but but let me just finally say this
this asinine i want to pay off student
debt is an insult to the senior citizens
to the people who pay taxes to people
who decide you know do i want to buy
meat this week or pay for my medicine
that's hogwash you got so many jobs you
got a great economy let them work and
pay off their bills just the way all of
us do that's the end of it greg you pay
your bills on time you know it sometimes
i pay early you're very very prudent yes
you know it's uh you know geraldo
started off by talking about russia the
problem is is that
russia doesn't upset americans what
upsets america is american problems if
you tell americans that you're going to
take their money
theft
to go pay for other people's loans
that will drive them crazy we already
have inflation we already have crime we
already have a a horrible border the
idea that we're gonna take a truck
driver's money
and pay the tuition of some art history
major with pink hair
sorry that's not gonna happen that's why
people people will react to this more
than they will react to a war thousands
of miles away even if the war is
horrible this is stuff that will like
that just says nope not gonna happen
here and i think i think by knows it's
not only is it not up to him
he is toast if he does this because it's
so there's no such thing as cancelling
debt it doesn't like disappear
1.6 trillion it will it will be paid by
us people that already paid off their
loans then they should start paying off
car loans they should start repaying the
people that paid their loans already
it's not going to happen i think penn
framed it perfectly because underlying
all of this the decades that he
mentioned who was in power joe biden all
of those decades he mentioned joe biden
was like zelig you know present in every
everything and he managed to pull the
worst memories of each
decade to create like a frankenstein
presidency right it's like america's
worst moments on on you know on one
single cd you know it's like the
opposite of greatest hits you got price
hikes you got crime waves you got gas
lines all that's missing is like a lyric
sheet for the hits you know and it just
what does it tell you
what we got is what we expected to get
he was clueless every single decade my
last point is we were oddly more
stressed out under trump
and there were fewer problems right many
fewer problems let's face it but we are
not we are let we feel less stressed out
with a lot of major problems going on
and the only way that i can figure this
out is that it's because the media had
elevated the the words of trump while
suppressing the deeds of biden because
really our hair should be on fire i mean
if this continues this inflation
continues and the crime wave doesn't go
away it's bad but we're like we're all
good well at least you know we don't see
trump's tweets well but it's putin's
fault right dana that's the real issue
none of that is sticking and i agree
with everything that you've said about
the student loan thing i'll just add a
couple of things
president biden knows this is bad policy
because when during the presidential
campaign he was the one that was like
standing a thought like i don't think
that's a very good idea but twice he has
extended the moratorium he got bullied
into it by the left and by twitter uh
they know it's
bad policy they're like their idea is
let's try to solve policy the poverty by
canceling the debt of graduate students
who have law and medical degrees yes
yeah suburban that's like solving the
hiv problem in africa by giving advil to
south america
none of that it doesn't work and here's
the other thing do you remember the
eviction moratorium and how mad people
got when you realized that those
landlords that were basically or the
people that were not paying the rent
were buying a speed boat taking
vacations and it got exposed and then
but it happened the administration tried
to pull back but they couldn't because
the member cory bush the congresswoman
she slept outside on the steps of the
capitol for several nights guess what
saved joe biden again the courts and i
would imagine that on the student loan
debt piece that they'll take all the
political pain from it
if he goes down this path and they'll
get saved by the courts or the taxpayers
will get saved by the courts once again
and on mark penn i would say that the
democrats always listen to him after
they've had some spectacular loss that's
true
can i just say one thing you know
i would throw into it into the group
think of the veterans who were homeless
do something for veterans that's all i
want to say i think that's a good point
i disagree
[Laughter]
all of you made really really really
great points this is a really great
conversation i'm proud of all of you i'm
going to slap you on the back
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else